подавай заяву до профтеху онлайн для
реєстрації кабінету вступника Зайди на
сторінку системи подання заяв в
електронній формі є debo створи
електронний кабінет і завантаж фото
розміром 3х4 медичну довідку додаток до
документа про освіту документи на пільги
Якщо маєш їх і не забудь вказати номер і
серію документу про раніше здобуток
освіту який самостійно підвантажиться в
кабінеті вступника обери модуль подача
заяви та заповнив обов'язкові поля
відсортуй конкурсні пропозиції та Обирай
які підходять тобі розгубився
Зателефонуй в підтримку електронного
кабінету вступника більше інформації на
сайті мон та в наших соцмережах
[музика]